folks this was this was a bit of a
banger we got heated we did our first
ever tournament today egg preparations
there were eight different egg
preparations we did uh four battles then
it worked
four brackets to two brackets to the
finale yes and it was very bad under
each other's skin we also talked about
uh where we started tattoos and
woodpeckers little tattoos little
woodpeckers yeah uh it was a great day
uh
i uh i'm still
oh go ahead no no i'm still i'm still
steaming from that yeah well what can
you do listen people uh we've got dates
coming up sit up when you speak to the
people
jesus
respect
despite you i won't do it
like a raise yourself people know that i
want to sit up right now i would like to
be sitting up but despite him i will not
sit up
but in my heart i'm sitting up i'm
standing up for all of you that's great
well this is come down to joey
if you're feeling this tension watch the
episode the joey rose's on the lower
east side of new york we're open tuesday
through
saturday sunday hey uh go to
joeyrosesnyc.com for dates
i mean information about the restaurant
and for my dates
joederosainfo.com i'll be headlining the
punchline in july and i've got other
dates coming up in the in the following
months
syracuse and rochester i will be there
in june check that out and as of last
week
on sale right this second is vegas
phoenix boulder colorado portland
seattle and vancouver all on sale right
now guys uh have not been through any of
those places yet savocanocomedy.com
on sale right now taste buds they coming
to the mic talking about the food they
hate talking about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds
are we rolling
hey folks
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buzz sal is back
and nervous because he doesn't he
doesn't have an insult for the salty
chance like last week we are in a
new location temporary right
uh we'll be back we'll be here a few
weeks on on both pods uh while i get
some construction done and uh that's it
we're you know this is the new thing we
got our sign here yeah thank you very
much it's comfy in here it's comf yeah
you know it's cold
we're doing also a first ever episode
today it's called the egg tournament
what we're gonna do is it's four
with a lightning round episode we
usually do four
three sorry three battles
with a tournament episode now we're
gonna do four take the winners of
wait a minute yeah that's too many
winners no the winners you have four
winners and then there's two more
battles and then one battle so these are
like three minutes each oh the okay you
get it it's just
even more lightning okay so even more
like one but only one stands victorious
yeah so we don't so we got a lot to
cover here so pimp
you're gonna time each round as let's
set it at four minutes
right three or do you think three do you
think three's a little short maybe four
four minutes okay four we'll think about
it we're doing four five six seven total
battles if we do them cleanly at four
that's 28 minutes about right yeah at
pimp you also need to get a pot and pan
to bang this out of the entire to get
salty
first of all it was pimp's idea to begin
with and it was really really funny but
then i and i know we just been trying to
start for like 20 minutes but i know
people like the bottom man when joe just
said that was just like
[Laughter]
pimp is back there drinking what looks
to be appears to be manure in a glass
what is that
newer yeah you said manor
[Laughter]
what is what is that pip i ordered a
smoothie i don't know it's a bunch of oh
that sounds delicious dude a smoothie
native one needed one that sounds
delicious dying today oh you know how
you make those really good peanut butter
raspberry bananas chocolate cocoa
smoothie things
maybe maybe two maybe two couple arrive
over here any time today
you could make it in between episodes
i can't have one of those i'm on a diet
oh really no no this is all i already
have my fruit for today
and now i'm having raisins on top of it
i got my insult
you got your insulin
i also can't have the chocolate why
because i have an allergy
uh best friend that i've explained this
to 87 times during the duration of a
friendship you could have yeah you
forget you could have pure cacao powder
cacao cacao i wouldn't waste my time
you're wrong
you're closed-minded on the cacao uh so
we got a lot to cover today let's do a
little talk about the bird and then
we're going to get into the chant and
then the eggs sure the bird
yeah the the animal that did the egg
comes from
okay oh we're going straight to the
source
yeah i'm saying you want to do a little
up top about the bird well you said you
wanted to talk about beaks before we
started rolling you said something about
you want to talk about beaks beaks
you said that beaks you literally said i
want to talk about
i would talk about beaks and i said yeah
well we'll talk about like chicken or
egg related stuff
what are you talking about you know i
didn't say it you said those words
didn't come out of my mouth you said you
wanted to talk about beaks you must have
misheard me would you say
i don't even know
what it could be
oh the beacon oh yeah
thank you
we just played the beacon and i'm like
yeah we'll talk about the beaks now i
get what you're saying all right so you
make cookies
yeah
i wanted to spend some time on chicken
beaks before we started we're talking
about i honestly did we're talking about
eggs well you know what you called it
out let's do it what what are beaks made
of
these bony parts are there bones
uh i guess so the sheath these bony
parts are covered with a sheath of a
tough material called keratin which i
think if i'm correct
women and
and men alike spend
top dollar to get keratin treatments in
their hair
keratin treatment i don't know if it's
the same thing as what's in a beak but
it's the same same stuff that makes up
tortoise shells the scales and claws of
reptiles and our own hair and
fingernails cacao the keratin sheath
makes the beak tough durable and shiny
well why do you oh it makes so i guess
it makes hair shiny
strong and shiny babe
the beak also contains numerous blood
vessels and nerve endings making it very
sensitive to pain they peck it into
trees for christ's sake yeah
and bleeding if it is injured and it is
connected to the skull if it's that
sensitive
what what happens would woodpeckers must
have migraines on the reg
i guess that's what makes them so
special pimp
google why don't woodpeckers feel pain
in their beaks
and why does god hate woodpeckers also
after that
well have you ever seen a woodpecker in
the wild
uh yeah you have rarely
[Laughter]
yeah i've come across one here or there
i know yeah it just i guess i would
assume it's rarely but i love how you
enforced it yeah no i've definitely i
know but where did you see it
where are they native to we can't see a
woodpecker here on the streets right not
in these up in these streets we can't
i've had one in queens you saw a
woodpecker in queens yeah i feel like i
saw them when i was a kid my cousin my
uncle uh and my uncle and aunt had a
camper in a campground that we would go
to
during the summer and i feel like i
would see a woodpecker there every once
in a while okay but i've never seen one
like
here i haven't seen an urban no not an
wild parrots here too wild parrots yeah
it's pretty cool what's a wild parrot
they're just native parrots hanging out
native to new york i guess so they're
wild we'll look at them after look at
this say babe woodpeckers have a special
bone that acts like a seat belt for
their skull it's called the
hyoid bone and it wraps all the way
around the woodpecker skull every time
the bird pecks the hyoid acts like a
seat belt
and and protects the birds
for the birds
it protects its brain and skull okay
but that doesn't i don't understand how
i feel i don't understand that
woodpeckers hit their heads up to 20
times a second
yeah my brain can't even compute that
but muscles bones and an extra eyelid
protect their small bird brains
strong dense muscles in the bird's neck
give it strength to repeatedly thump its
head but it is extra muscles in the
skull that keep the bird from getting
hurt there you go so pimp can we can we
can we see a video of a woodpecker in
action
oh here we go yeah let's get some
woodpecker action
all right slow-mo is this slo-mo or
fasmo
slo-mo oh this is wild my whole entire
life i've never watched a woodpecker in
slow motion
it sounds like it looks like it's
painting it's the first time for me in
40
in 40 something years i've never done
that like they go fully
out dude yo wow the the beak actually
penetrates the wood
yeah like i mean but
i mean it went in there like halfway the
first strike but what's interesting
they're saying 20 times in a second
it goes in and pulls all the way out
again it's not like it goes in and then
stays in like a jackhammer what is that
his end game here the woodpecker he's
not eating the wood no you're eating
worms in there right i thought they make
a home this way
yeah like that's what it is
he's making a hole in the side of that
tree
is it to extract
bugs and worms or is it like
he's going to go in there and hang out
yeah for nesting and a marking of
territory and for fun all of it they're
looking for insects
if the birds are looking for insects the
holes will be smaller and irregular uh
woodpeckers are particularly fond of the
larvae of carpenter bees leaf cutter
bees and grass bag worms none of which
i've ever heard of i've heard of a
carpenter bee but um
wow that's wild so wait let's see a
woodpecker in regular speed though i
want to see how fast it looks
here we go this is hysterical we're
doing a tournament about eggs today
i have a question about that
who are these two
these are two woodpeckers i guess that
went in and got food
are they all red-headed like that
uh i don't know all i think it's common
it's a sharp looking bird no that guy's
not woody woodpecker is red-headed so i
feel like that's common enough that they
made him red-headed
do woodpeckers
just fly like every other bird yeah
right
yeah yeah but woody doesn't fly
uh he's got he's doing other things
yeah but they they never they never
showed him fly it's not really a show
about that though
yeah but he runs fast
that's not 20 times a second
come on
[ __ ] 20 times a second
put in like fastest woodpecker
but seriously you saw like that was like
that was like once every two seconds
yeah he was taking his time for sure on
that one
all right
let's see some action here this guy oh
this guy's a red mohawk this guy is
sleek
unless it's going so fast you can't
no we're watching it no he's just like
wow they really
they do some damage
is there a woodpecker attacking a human
here i want to see how oh that would be
wonderful
it had to have happened right
it's got oh man oh my god for someone to
catch it here we go
i mean it must just is it gonna attack
this child put a hole in you dude but
that's not a woodpecker
no
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh my god
it's straight up just just dive-bombing
into this guy's head
repeatedly
but it didn't hurt him
he's wearing a wildlife conservation
shirt as well
and now there's a woman
is that a woodpecker though
i mean you deserve what you get at this
point he's holding the thing
it's a sleek looking bird
what's a firebird
is that a real thing car
right but is it from a bird i don't
think so is
it that's that's a crazy way to feed my
god is that a snake oh my god oh my god
that snake was in the tree
holy sh
the woodpecker went back to fight the
snake
and the snake just literally bit it
oh god is there anything more evil
looking than that no
sarah's coming out of a tree
pimp can we eat woodpecker
look at this i have look at this yeah
it's disgusting
well i hate snakes
i know
i hate snakes chuck
jock
it's not chuck it's jack
it's jacques yeah
he doesn't say chuck no jock i hate
snakes jacques i hate him oh wow
uh can you eat
come a monk
but can we eat woodpecker eggs
doesn't say
no it's insane let's see
would woodpeckers be anywhere without
woody at this point though nowhere there
would be no way without no one would
give a [ __ ]
it's a nasty bird that pecks things let
me ask you a question i bet it's a nasty
bird you just see him or some attack a
guy yeah an unarmed man yeah yeah you
what is your question about uh woody
is he an [ __ ]
yeah he is right yeah he's kind of a
pain in the ass
who's his nemesis
i don't know i don't remember ever being
terribly fond of the show yeah but he
has to have a nemesis now
like otherwise what was he doing the
whole episode it was always about me
versus you back he's an [ __ ] like the
way like i think the way like daffy duck
is an [ __ ] you know what i mean like
daffy duck has an attitude problem
but woody i think is more like
he's just
an obnoxious
well i think he's kind of like bugs
bunny bugs bunny's kind of an [ __ ] so
you're right a lot of them are you know
but that's
you know daffy duck was my fave
and maybe that's what maybe that's why i
like you yeah how did you know daffy
duck was my fault i didn't oh i said it
was mine and you said it was yours are
you here no no you said that you know
daffy duck was my fave and maybe that's
why i like you as i was saying me too oh
because i think you're the
personification of daffy duck oh you do
yeah it's time to get salty it's time to
get salty it's time to get salty
i am yeah all right i mean i never
thought about it
i never thought until just now give me a
little story
when i was going to get my first ever
tattoo at the age of 18
because that's uh back then
you were they didn't have them in new
york
it was illegal didn't have tattoos no no
no tattoo
shops in new york for
only like the last 15 plus years right
anyway you had to be 18 in jersey and
had to prove it my dad at the time was
like
just about turning 50 just about yeah 97
yeah oh well as long as i thought but i
do so i was i was turning 18
in uh
in 94.
no sorry yeah 94. yeah and so three
years before it was legal so we went to
jersey and i went to this place i think
it was called it was right over the
gothel's bridge
it was it was like the only place we
would go here i go to get it and i went
in and i looked at everything they had
you know i should have known better i
should have thought of like something
original i want to put on but i didn't
know any better so i went in i looked at
all the you know like you're looking at
posters and spencers and stuff and i'm
looking at all the wall the sheet on the
walls and everything and i'm like yeah
nothing here is really jumping out to me
i don't know and my dad was like oh you
gotta get something like it was like a
special moment bonding moment between us
he had just gotten a tattoo his first
and so i was like i guess so yeah i
don't want to i don't want to get
something i don't want and then i swear
i had i was completely stumped and the
last couple of seconds i flipped through
a book that had like cartoons in it and
there was a daffy duck and i was just
gonna get something on my ankle and i go
i
i said to the guy and by the way i don't
remember this but back then
i don't know why it's not much like as
much like this anymore but at least here
tattoo
artists were complete [ __ ]
yeah they were mean they were arrogant
yeah they still can be yeah it was like
but it was bad it was like they were
almost like
like uh you know like like that's scary
but it was like they were just so
like as for for 18 years ago going into
a biker bar yeah it was like that right
yeah yeah so i said uh maybe i'll get it
maybe i'll all right fine maybe i'll
maybe i'll get a daffy duck or whatever
and the guy was like
and i was like he goes yeah you look
like a cartooner when you came in here
and i was like well i'm just saying that
i didn't want to get daffy but you guys
are all telling me i have to get
something so i was like i was just
trying to like get something so did you
get it no so i i was like after that i
was like fine do you have like a [ __ ]
skull killing a devil or something what
do you want me to get right uh and then
he takes out a book i swear to you and
he goes what about this this is
something like newer
and i open it up and it is um tribal
tattoos
they had not been around before that and
when i looked at it i looked at it and i
had not seen them they weren't taken
over by muscle guys yet and and tan
spray tans and guidos
they weren't it was just more like a i
don't know what and it wasn't like
tribal like authentic tribal you know it
was a design and and i was like oh i've
never seen that before right so i said
i'll take that
so in 1996
i got
this tattoo
instead of daffy duck god around your
i was a grunge guy had long hair and
everything i just was like around the
ankle it's terrible it's a terrible
tattoo it's the worst tattoo i've i have
and i would never i would never ever get
it right
i i didn't i wasn't gonna get it around
my arm i thought it was stupid ankles
like that's up there with cleavage
well i i almost got it on my tits
no uh
all right i was you know i'm very happy
that i i'm right now i'm thrilled that i
got sure yeah yeah yeah but i got it and
then um
fast forward i used to be a cash
registered guy at the deli uh not far
from here and i'm i'm at the deli and a
guy walks in it's like three months
later and he goes it's and it's like a a
guy and he has it around his arm and
it's the exact one
and i looked at him and i go oh my god
he goes what i go i have that tattoo and
he goes no not this tattoo and i go no
i said i have that exact tattoo and he
goes that's impossible i said why he
goes because i got it at this place
and i paid the guy
extra money to make me a one-of-one
and i showed him my ankle
and he turned like five shades of
redness goes that [ __ ] he goes
way like he goes i'm going there right
now we're like at this guy
so the guy like was
he wasn't genuine any and he sold he
sold that guy's one of one to me
so i know this wait the same place yes
jesus you're same artist what a piece of
[ __ ] doug his name was
doug sucks now how is it having ocd and
tattoos they don't bother you
what do you mean like like the the
design i don't know it would bother me
tattoos bother me some of them do so if
they fade or get compromised or anything
like that this one is another one i got
it on a road trip april 2003 in new
orleans with q we took a minivan down
there five friends we all got tattoos
this was mine i got it at electric lady
land in new orleans in the corner there
and uh they put me with this kid and i
asked her a cross right there and he did
it and i i later came to find out he was
like kind of new and they threw me to
him and this entire cross is completely
lopsided and all [ __ ] yeah it doesn't
look that good thank you so much for
that yeah and uh
19 years later i still think about this
kid his name was bailey you could get
that easily altered on to something i
don't even want it anymore
or we'll remove then yeah yeah but you
know what i feel i feel like i got it
and it's been part of me and it's part
of like what my decisions i made so i
just kind of leave it but it does i
don't like that one either
yeah i mean that's what i say you can
get that altered into something
it's simple enough that it could become
something else you didn't get like
[Music]
there you go
why not
why not one of our fans got my face
tattooed on him yeah yeah wow
commitment yeah i know i've seen that i
tell them not to but they do it yeah i
have two uh sale of jerry like type
hearts on my legs with my all my
grandparents initials on them i have
this one which is some lyrics for a
friend which i like and then i have two
two uh very accurate portraits of jaden
smith on both eyes that's nice yeah all
right we weren't going to get into we
went from woodpeckers to tattoos we're
supposed to be doing an egg 20 let's go
ready yeah you ready for the chant yeah
all right do you want to install first
you want me to install first
whatever
whatever you like
no you can pick okay pick god be my
guest all right ready yeah
it's time to get salty it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty that's
entire story you told about your tattoos
was the most boring [ __ ] thing i've
ever heard of my life
i was sinking
back into this couch i swear to god i
was almost nodding off i knew you know i
saw that i was just friends i saw his
eyes glazed and then i started to
fantasize as you were telling it i'm
serious what if we were just here
regular hanging out and sal was telling
me the story and i the only reason i can
fake interest right now sort of is
because there's cameras
yeah i i don't know how i would have sat
through it if we were at a dinner party
i told another slow side i am in a
relaxed state and i am trying to just
deliver everything i'm saying relax i
think
okay fair enough
i forgot about that i forgot about that
completely ready but yeah it's time to
get salty it's time to get salty it's
time to get salty i think they should do
a dna test on you or even cut a leg out
and look at the rings inside to see how
old you actually are because i suspect
you are a [ __ ] 95 year old man why oh
you're allergic to cocoa you got
complaints about everything one after
the other you're very disagreeable yeah
you're very curmudgeonly there's no way
everything is younger than me did you
ever think it's you there's no way did
you ever think it's you nobody thinks
it's me
i swear to god you should be in like bad
grandpa too they just throw a little
white in your hair and that's it you're
done you're already dead it's over
follow the rules
all right egg battles here we go
scramble versus sunnyside which you
taking we didn't even i know i forgot
i'll tell you what i want sunny side
scrambled good ready time to b-a-t-t-l-e
buds all right pip start the clock
sunny side up
kills scrambled
a thousand times over and i'm gonna tell
you why in one fell swoop
you
get the egg part by cutting off the
white part and you get your salt and
peppery egg part there right and that
complements your savory part of the
breakfast and then you pop
that yellow and it runs on the plate and
you take that toast and you dunk it and
you it's a whole experience man
scrambled can't hold a candle i knew
that the one place you were going to go
to was just dunking the bread in the
runniness and i'll tell you something
the runniness sometimes works for me but
more times than not
it does not it feels like an egg
a plate it is disgusting it's it feels
uh phlegm like it it it has this
consistency that that actually is very
very off-putting and sometimes i'm in
the process of dunking my bread and in
the middle of it i'm like just power
through this because it feels like i'm
eating egg phlegm
and by the way i dunked more than the
toast in it i dunked the bacon in it
i i i another thing is it looks so nice
but once you pop it and it runs it very
evenly coats the full surface of the
plate and it it then ends up like you
can't even get if you don't have bread
you're not eating that yolk you can't
get it up with a fork you gotta drag it
and it falls off and it's well i don't
know what world i don't know what world
you would order sunny side up eggs
without having toast available if they
said we don't have toast i'd say well
then forget it it's it's very limiting
and you pop those yolks at the end i eat
around the oaks and make perfect circles
of the yolks last thing i do
pop them dunk dunk dunk and then eat the
the eggs that's great but it still feels
like uh a chicken did a snot rocket into
your plate and you're trying to like
cover it with rye well what i what i'm
saying is another thing about sunnyside
is they lose the heat retention very
quickly a lot of times if you drop that
plate down scramble does not scramble
does not scramble holds pockets of heat
if you hit a scramble three minutes into
eating it you'll see a burst of steam
come out there's nothing to me better
than fluffy buttery beautiful scrambled
eggs i hate butter in a scrambled egg i
can't stand a butter flavor in a
scrambled egg i think it's gross and i
will tell you this scrambled eggs when
done properly with that little bit of
runniness to them are wonderful
most of the time they are they are
screwed up by the chef most of the time
they're dry
they've got crustiness to them because
they were overcooked in the pan it is
very hard to complement most egg dishes
the best basically an omelette is is the
cousin of the scrambled egg if i'm
getting an egg a bacon egg and cheese
sandwich it's
for me quintessentially it's got to be
scrambled you understand what i'm saying
i think come on dude
if you say that what is a quintessential
egg breakfast when you say
eggs toast bacon
breakfast mean i'm thinking scrambled in
that place thick and sunny side up and a
sunny-side up
egg on a breakfast sandwich is unreal
dude the runniness dude p you put a
sunny-side up egg on a burger people do
that all the time dude and the yolk
running down that burger meat with the
bacon and everything oh damn the sunny
side i don't know if there's sushi
dishes though i don't love the yogurt it
looks like it looks like it was flash
cooked it looks like it's almost going
to be raw and then you and then you poke
it it just just it just runs everywhere
it just it's it's it's even thinking of
it you know what you are running it's
runny you know what else is running a
runny nose you know what you are you
know you are you're a guy that likes
like a well done steak you eat like a
child you know like
except the only thing is i don't like my
stakes like that but you know what i
don't know no but but you do but you
just said i didn't i don't but you do
but i don't right
now you cannot go
like when you were kids you'd be like
mommy i only want ketchup on my burger
because you you couldn't handle the
toppings you know what i mean you have a
limited powder you're off your rocker
already listen to me scrambled is more
fun to make you whip it up you pour it
in and then you like
we have more time it's fluffy but that's
time all right well i think you know
you went down to flames also can i just
say no no you can't just squish it
around combine the egg and the yolk and
the white to make i'm not looking better
than the sum of their problems listening
it's over we get tired all right follow
the rules i'm just saying sorry pimp
folks we want to talk to you about pear
eyewear
pear eyewear pear i wear oh wow it's the
pair i wear i wonder if they knew they
were doing that
uh i i'm a big believer in eyewear not
just because i need it because i also
find that it adds something to my
personal genesequoir persona it helps me
express myself your individuals it lets
people know my flavor
maybe when i'm approaching from a
distance maybe you know maybe in an
initial conversation this used to work
with my long hair
i like it i think it looks nice i think
it looks fashion forward
and i think that what pair i wear is
doing is fashion forward in the sense
that they're letting you create
eyewear that's perfect for you perfect
for your expression perfect for your
style it's pretty cool they've got base
frames with magnetic top frames that
combined and then you can switch things
up whenever you feel like you change the
look of your glasses like that so cool
bass frames starting just at 60 bucks
that's including the lenses that's
another great thing they're doing
affordable eyewear is
crazy because it gets expensive
there are hundreds of top frame designs
to match whichever base terms you want
this is a genius idea this is like
something i would have seen on shark
tank and i swear to god why has no one
done this up until now i don't know i
mean we keep buying different lenses to
put in a pair of glasses attached to a
lens but you can't change your style
yeah i know it is it is brilliant paris
where they forged their own way and
their designs and all their looks it's
all done in-house which is really cool
you're gonna get high quality eyewear at
the fraction of a price i love what
these guys are doing uh every frame
comes in six different colorways
including black all the way to blue
tortoise uh
yeah that's it for every pair purchased
this is cool for repair purchase pair
eyewear provides glasses and vision care
for children around the world very very
cool so get glasses as unique as you are
one pair infinite style starting at just
60 bucks go to peariewear.com tastebuds
for 15 off your first purchase that's 15
off at p-a-i-r-iware.com
taste buds
you know what i like i like coffee you
know when i like it i'll tell you all
day throughout the day you could
probably tell i drink a lot of it by my
demeanor but here's the thing
i like to switch it off and i like
switch it up
i haven't had my coffee
yet i like coffee to fit my taste and my
taste palette and that's where trade
coffee comes in all right they're
basically curating the freshest and
best-tasting coffees from around the
world they partner with the country's
best crafted uh exactly exactly it's
really really cool it's
in the business i said from around the
world accidentally but i'll tell you
what goes on in my mouth when i drink
trade coffee i feel that i'm on an
international journey okay now getting
flavors from all over if they get them
from independent businesses from big
cities and small towns uh from all
around
trade customers are truly impactful for
the independent uh for these independent
resellers i like the dune flavor myself
uh trades coffee team actually does
taste testing for you they're taste
testing thousands of coffees to keep 450
kinds of coffee live and ready to ship
every day
trade is so confident also that they'll
match you with the right flavor the
first time because they do an algorithm
yeah human-powered algorithm babe to
help you pinpoint what coffee you like
and they do a first match guarantee so
yeah and by the way they'll take your
feedback and an actual coffee expert
will work with you to send you a brand
new bag
for free that's their guarantee and
they're so confident shrimp scrimp
i just called you scrimp
what they'll do is they will match you
if you're not happy with an actual
coffee expert who will work with you to
send you a brand new bag for free that's
their guarantee that's pretty cool
that's cool
so
[Laughter]
listen they've already delivered over 5
million bags of fresh coffee to more
than 750 000 positive reviews um you
take this quiz you answer a couple of
questions you get your own personalized
variety of coffees delivered coffee
coffee coffee delivered fresh to you as
often as you like there aren't any
gimmicks right now trade is offering new
subscribers a total of 30 off the first
order plus free shipping that's a great
deal all you got to do is go to
drinktrade.com tastebuds that's
drinktrade.com tastebuds and it's more
than 40 cups of coffee for free with
this deal get started by taking their
quiz at drinktrade.com taste buds and
let trade find a coffee that you're
going to love that's drinktrade.com
taste buds for 30 off this is the round
next round
is
hard boiled versus poached which do you
want i could go either way but i think i
will take hard-boiled okay i'll take
poached for the same reasons i took
sonny's
[Laughter]
all right here we go go ahead a poached
egg while
i think they are
a thing of beauty and they are hard to
pull off it takes a skilled person to
make a proper poached egg they're good
but the same thing ends up happening
though you break it open and it's just
mucus shooting out and running toward
the edges of the plate and you got to
sop up the mucus into your mouth and
it's just it just it just coats
everything some people put it on like a
salad you ever see that like you put an
egg yolk in like arugula yes it's a
sophisticated it feels like a slime
right now i have a hard-boiled egg
baby it feels like but it feels like
slimer ran through the arugula it's just
it's just good
you make a decent you make a decent
point with this guck
i'm mixing
you make a decent point with the
sliminess of a runny yolk but you can
only make it oh my god many times the
other word is definitely definitely not
a good word as far as if you're applying
it to
people's uh you're just worried about no
that's not where i was going with that
you can only let's all back up you can
only make this point so many times yes
there's a there's a sliminess or there
can be something to a runny yolk okay
you made your point but but that doesn't
matter anybody that likes a poached egg
doesn't mind that they enjoy the
consistency of the yolk i am one of
those people a poached egg is these are
both hard dishes to make properly but a
poached egg is much harder to make than
a hard-boiled egg i'll tell you much
harder and again you want to talk
breakfast sandwiches you want to talk
accoutrement to a fancier salad the
poached egg i mean forget it dude this
is yeah this is game over i like a
poached egg better than a sunny side up
egg but i'll tell you what right now it
for me it does not beat a hard-boiled
egg i think a hard-boiled egg i grew up
on them okay i
i think they're absolutely delicious i
was in the airport two days ago flying
home from vermont i bought two of them
look i had a heartbeat i like cracking
them i like making them i like cracking
them and rolling them and then peeling
there is something so satisfying about
rolling and cracking that shell and then
peeling it off and the membrane on the
inside of the shell sticks together and
it peels off and there's this beautiful
smooth i mean you want a car and the
whole the whole thing gets undressed on
one piece first of all it's almost like
the the top of the smooth peanut butter
the egg it just peels off and the egg
reveals it first of all
you talk disgusting you want to talk
disgusting shell membrane there's no
grosser word than membrane first of all
that's true and i know
second of all that shell is peeling off
one way and one way only with ease while
you're running it under water okay now i
put in my hands and i go like this it's
still not coming off easily you got to
run that underwater when you peel it
almost every time
you just hit it with a little bit of
salt and it's piping hot or not
or even salt how about this you ever
ever hard boiled egg without salt it
tastes like it tastes like egg cake if
you don't put salt on that it tastes
like you're eating an eggy sponge it's
just thick too okay to make and chewy
and it's something you have with salt
and pepper it's gorgeous babe i like
biting it and saving i said with salt
i said if you have to eat it without
easter
the bunny knows what he's doing the
bunny knows because the hard-boiled eggs
at easter i mean it is it is the calling
card of one of the most major holidays
buying the eggs you mean yeah but it's
with hard-boiled eggs and then you put
them in a basket and then over the next
couple days you eat them yeah dying the
eggs is fine i guess you know who cares
yeah but again you talk like a child
they don't serve poached eggs on easter
you talk like a child though this is a
childish thing this is back to my other
point yeah yeah it's fun to color the
eggs i mean what are you three no i
think
i said
even the easter egg the holiday of
easter utilizes a hard-boiled egg it has
it ha it has it serves functions
daily daily breakfast utilizes the
poached
what's your point how about the water
poached eggs involved in breakfast far
more than i do talk about membranes i
mean word poached is a bad word too no
poach calls up all sorts of negatives
not a bad word
animals
that's time
now do we see who's won these two battle
no
we can but we have to decide who goes
against who in the next one so we should
just run the four and then then make the
baton new back we run three because we
said we were going to leave caviar
cadbury up to the fan strictly okay so
we have one more battle okay all right
ready
uh wait what is it
it is uh oh deviled versus devil vs raw
i'm taking devil i'll give you devils i
can't take role after i just complained
about the other ones europe shit's creek
uh i offered you egg salad babe you said
no
i didn't think that deviled eggs should
be part of this because they're not a
natural preparation of just an egg
you're adding ingredients no no i didn't
want to take egg salad because i thought
egg salad was egg i got news for you
buddy none of this is natural
preparation
every part of this is not a natural raw
is the only natural version
i mean without any other ingredients
babe okay salt and pepper and
ingredients you know what i mean dude
but you know several days you're adding
bacon you're adding chocolate you're
writing mustard you're getting out of
here you're adding mayo what are you
talking about you're adding ingredients
to the egg and that's why i didn't want
to take egg salad because it's the same
thing it's not true and also i think
really exiled is very much like uh
deviled eggs just mashed up now you got
raw eggs you better start arguing it
because the clock is ticking it's wrong
to make me argue against something i
clearly was against in the last two
battles but you agreed to it
you know what
you know what you know what i'll accept
raw because raw is raw it's not putting
on airs okay it knows what it is and
it's and you're drinking it for that
reason you either rocky balboa or you're
at the gym or you're getting salmonella
whatever you whatever you're doing with
it
it's not trying to hide it knows that
you know that you're eating it raw okay
it's not trying to be like well you kind
of cooked me and then all of a sudden it
just goes and it boards itself all over
you you know what i'm saying and
i think it's the health like the most
the purest and most protein packed way
to consume an egg
which is why the bodybuilders and the
people that care about mass
drink it
and uh you know i've never dr have you
ever had a reich
you have no way
what context
i eat a raw egg
like you were just home and like i'll
swallow a royal rocky and i wanted to
try it so i tried it so as a child yeah
and i think once i did it as a
yeah no as a child yeah i tried yeah you
never had vanilla what about the
salmonella i i i didn't do it now i
can't uh eggs don't carry salmonella
it's not like raw chicken i don't know
really
well is there any danger to consuming
raw eggs
using pasteurized eggs lessens the
possibility
may contain salmonella
may though it's not like like chicken
with chicken it's like yeah you know
so yeah i hear you should the loser
drink a raw egg
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know if i can do it
i would do it i'm basically like a raw
egg too halloween
she's pelting somebody world roy all of
a sudden food becomes ammo
you know what i'm saying
a raw egg it's not just like you know
eat me for bodybuilding or you know use
me it's like take me i'm part of the fun
yeah the egg really uh dip finds its way
into different holidays now that i'm
talking about it i'm just letting you
run out the clock i mean i'm cuz you got
nothing to say no i got the winning i
got the winning team here i don't need
to work hard in this round i'm just
going to let you talk to yourself
and it has that like
coating that like that coating on top of
it like it's been it's been out in the
air for a while look you can't even
begin to talk down about a deviled egg
devil's oh look at that oh spaghetti oh
devil that's disgusting
deviled eggs are awesome there is
nothing more exciting at a barbecue than
a plate of deviled eggs i get so excited
what's a deviled egg i never had one oh
pimp it's basically a hardcore you take
a hard ball take the yolk out and you
add all different ingredients to it like
mustard mayo
chives bacon bits whatever you want to
do and there's tons of and then you mix
that up and then you put that back in to
that this half and it is awesome
interesting cause you trashed mayo in
that texture in the last episode yeah
what did i do you said you can't handle
mayo it makes you ralph no no i said
mayo
no no i said i like mayo but certain
types mayo in certain scenarios makes me
grossed out
i just was saying i like to poach dig
better i love a deviled egg it lights up
a barbecue it's delicious it's wonderful
and i love you
and that's time i would never pick up a
deviled egg at a at a barbecue
on a table outside in the heat
oh god who who brings deviled eggs to a
barbecue i don't know who keeps talking
past the time limit sal volcano who
doesn't respects the rules of the show
sal volcano who spits in my face as his
co-host sal volcano
all right let's see where we're at you
know these these tournaments can't be
four minutes of me giving tons of great
reasons pro and khan about these eggs
and then you smirking going that's the
pot and pan that was the only one i did
that on because if there's no way raw is
beating devil things
so you know i had the judge's decision
and i waited the clock out all right pip
let's see who won each battle so then we
can take it to the next uh round
scrambled versus sunny at 5600 votes we
have a winner on
scramble
62.5 to 37.5 it's a decent w there
that's a decent w okay so sal you have
scrambled
and scrambled is now going to go against
no it's got to go to uh poached and
hard-boiled
poached hard-boiled has 4 200 votes
hard-boiled 61.7 about the same spread
well now here's a problem because you
have scrap no no no no no no we got to
see who won the other two okay and if
you win those two we can put them up
against each other okay i got it
question though where are you taking
cadbury caviar
cadbury's gonna crush caviar really what
side am i on yeah
i've never eaten caviar and i don't
really like cadbury eggs but i'm
inclined to take cadbury eggs but bet on
the pony
i'm going to bet on caviar
really i was going to bet on cabbage i'm
sorry i'm going to bet on cadbury okay
that's my bet okay see this sucks
because we both know cadbury's gonna win
and and
take cadbury babe caviar is all right
i'll take cadbury caviar is uh one of
the finer things all right what do we
got cadbury versus caviar did you guys
even argue that yet no it's just we're
saying that i think it's a great great
battle i honestly don't know who would
win that
it's either going to be a like 90 to 10
cadbury or it's going to be very close i
don't know
i can't tell but
he didn't have either and doesn't like
either and so we like decided to let
that one be the fans
let's see what they say cadbury vs
caviar drum rolls on all of these babes
but this is not the final
uh humble pod 4 200 votes cadbury caviar
pimp's choosing caviar like a line
oh wow
86.8
13.1 okay so i got cadbury right now you
have scrambled and hard boil
and then let's go to the last one
deviled versus raw i mean come on it's
got to be deviled right
i think you should have it i think you
should have it
uh we have 4 200 votes deviled at 84
versus sixteen percent roughly for raw
okay so now we go to the brexit now now
i gotta tweet these
okay so next brackets so pimp cut all
this part out is coming i just opened up
my terrace and i put in a new tank in
the bbq and i am ready to start
grilling or asking my lady to grill for
me because i don't know how to do it so
you got some juice in the tank you got
something you're cooking with gas that's
correct and this is where butcher box
comes in babes we talk about it all the
time we love it it's a meat delivery
subscription service
cheaper than the store i love it i love
this only the best meats and cuts i say
it every time i love cancel anytime i
love the steaks i love this thing 15
pounds of meat right to your doorstep
i love the steak so much 100 grass-fed
beef for amazing prices this is so hard
to find in a supermarket
without prices that are fluctuating
greatly or honestly ripping you off
butcher boxes giving you the right food
for the right price and with the right
service by making it convenient for you
i love that it's all uh vacuum packed
and frozen so you free range organic
chicken freezer salmon
you you know and here's the other thing
too with new subscribers right now we
usually give a deal uh and this is a new
one because of the spring you order now
new subscribers get a free grilling
bundle with their first order that's
really great no antibiotics in this food
no hormones added
packed fresh and shipped frozen for
convenience as i said by the way i just
want to put an emphasis on that i love
the frozen element i know i always say
that but here's what i really mean by
that sometimes i go to the grocery store
and i fill the fridge and i feel like it
is a ticking time bomb i am i am i'm
over eating because things are going to
start going bad right all right uh i
love that this meat is coming properly
packaged and frozen so i do not have to
race to enjoy it uh anyway so customize
a box or choose from their selections
okay kick off grilling season right with
butcher box sign up at butcherbox.com
tastebuds to receive a free grilling
bundle on your first order you'll get
two 10 ounce ribeyes five pounds of
chicken drumsticks and a pack of burgers
for fry for free
butcherbox.com taste buds go claim this
deal all right babe so here we go now we
have the winners of the tournaments and
what we got we got now is deviled versus
hard boiled and we got cadbury versus
scramble right so now i think the round
should drop down to three minutes
okay
by the way final rounds 40 minutes
final round should just be two minutes
all right because you've already made
the case yeah yeah all right let's go
first cadbury versus scramble ready pimp
you got the clock
here we go
come on dude cad barry egg everybody
loves a cat very excited
you can't win a loan just based on the
fact that it is just an outlier as a
goof
no one's gonna put like if people are
considering eggs seriously
they need the staple of the scrambled
egg in their life they're not gonna go
with a fair weather friend you demanded
you demanded cadbury be in this
tournament today
even with your
fury about the deviled egg taking
preparation of some kind because cadbury
you demanded that this egg be involved
as if this comes out of a natural
chocolate chicken somewhere i thought it
was funny to put against caviar for sure
look at me cadbury cream eggs i never
got into them why they're just not good
you know they just feel like you're
eating
like straight sugar like it's like the
yolk is just
it just feels too much and then there's
that weird yellow dye in the middle it
just doesn't feel right scrambled eggs
scrambled eggs are for willie lohmann
okay they're for
they're for traveling salesmen
scrambled eggs for traveling salesman
and strippers and strippers that just
got off of work okay
sunday morning breakfast with your kids
you're talking brunch i'm talking i'm
talking i just got into town uh what's
open oh it was a cadbury egg for a thief
let me tell you how loved the cadbury
egg is they used to have commercials
announcing the return of the cadmium
they know how to market it dude by the
way
by the way cadbury they reduced the eggs
by half the size didn't tell anybody
anything what's wrong with that
for you eggs are bad for you oh what a
stupid argument what's wrong with that
hey what about what what cost versus
value
i was paying the same price for double
the category i couldn't handle a whole
cadbury egg it was too big so i never
got into it as a child i didn't even
like cadbury eggs i think they're
overrated i think a very small section
of the population actually likes them
but they're fervent
fervent
about it and i think that's what keeps
the category people turn to this show
for one thing
fun look at that especially
happiness joy that's why people turn to
the show if you want to do this i think
they want to see if you walked into an
entertainer
of a human car accident if you walked
into an inflatable castle that was
labeled
funplex
and when you walked in the host of the
funplex handed you a cadbury egg you'd
say exactly if he handled you scrambled
eggs you'd throw him in his face and say
what the hell kind of fun plex i drop a
plate of cadbury eggs in front of you
and a beautiful piping hot fresh plate
of scrambled eggs you eating the plate
of cadbury eggs listen it depends on
what i'm in the mood for but nobody's
excited about scrambled eggs is my point
people get excited about a cadbury joe
on the basis alone that the cadbury egg
is a once in a while
low end confectionary treat versus the
literal mount rushmore of egg
scrambled egg you think that cadbury's
gonna beat
you got the last word if you're happy
no you just you don't need to talk now
for an extra 30 seconds all right here
we go hard-boiled versus deviled
whoa
it's deviled it takes the hard-boiled it
makes it better what is what is even the
art you can't have a deviled egg without
a hard boiled who cares you can't you
can't plant without dirt it doesn't mean
i want to eat the dirt without a
hard-boiled but without a hard-boiled
egg you have a bowl full of mustard mayo
and chives that's what you have you need
me you need me what are you talking
about you need us what are you talking
about you need a hard-boiled egg to make
it what are you talking about you need a
hard-boiled egg to make it you know what
else i need a chicken
to make you
okay do i
i don't understand it the egg comes out
of it
yeah but what does that have to do with
me
what does it i'm saying everything needs
another thing to get here yeah it
doesn't mean the other thing is better i
need an egg
a chicken egg to make me
no your your argument the hard-boiled
egg not you said you no i know but i
meant like your thing i'm saying like
all right we don't have time for this
listen
my point is is everything anything
that's great comes from something that
is less great and that's what the
deviled egg is it is greatness made from
less greasy it's also cheating in this
tournament oh my god
it's not cheating
it's only it's the only thing with extra
ingredients it's not just the egg in a
preparation literally has no part of an
egg that is that along with caviar was
the nod wild card card caviar is an egg
right
cat i'm saying but cat berry doesn't
even have some egg in it that was the
joke it's a one-off i love when it's his
choice that it's this is a joke
it's my choice it doesn't count the
cadmium
is it is the joker it's a wild card it's
funny is it the shape of an egg it's the
joker because of course that's the word
that's like saying deviled eggs should
go against an omelette though you know
it's you're preparing the egg sure it's
not just
i gave you the option you denied it i i
honestly think that doesn't matter here
we are here we are something about
dropping the devil if a deviled egg is
sitting for more than five minutes
i end up recoiling it's this simple it's
this simple platter of deviled eggs goes
out at food gatherings barbecues
sometimes at a holiday meal there's a
there's a platter of deviled eggs easter
they come along with easter dinner
sometimes
uh
hard-boiled eggs never
never ever ever do you go to a food
event like a barbecue at a friend's
house and see a pallet of hard-boiled
eggs it never happens
why
because it was a very seldomly eaten
form of event a place you won't see
deviled eggs too i'm not talking about
where you'd find hard-boiled eggs i'm
just talking about which one is more
palatable and for me it's a hard-boiled
egg come on i love the process of making
i can eat
moisturizers
that's how i can eat a hard boiled egg
[Laughter]
somebody who knows illustration make
just make me a joe derosa caricature
with a heaping plate of hard-boiled eggs
and he's just sucking him down without
chewing like a goddamn seagull
[Music]
we're doing this very quickly so there's
only a couple thousand votes here maybe
but
uh devil versus hard-boiled versus
hard-boiled come on hard-boiled
[ __ ]
devil 55-45
deviled okay oh man well you might have
a problem here cadbury might take
scramble oh no no
wait is 55 to 45 too close to coal and
with 1700 votes no it's your show guys i
don't know no it's all right we're
letting it ride we're letting it ride
we're letting it ride all right ready
cadbury versus scrambled uh-oh yes all
right
yes so so
58.6 percent
to 41.4 percent scramble takes cadbury
final round the egg you didn't want in
it went to the top baby
because there's ingredients in them oh
it's my favorite preparation of the eggs
you know you're losing the scrambled
right
we'll see yeah baby let me put it in
we'll see scrambled only did 58 over
cadbury dude that's not that's not you
know it should have smothered cadbury
it's the staple egg as you put it here
we go final round folks
final battle
we've got
we've got scrambled versus deviled this
is after a an eight egg preparation
tourney our first ever yeah our first
ever this is the exclamation point
and i want to point out again because i
know i only said it a second ago but i'm
going to put it out again just to rub
your nose in it what egg did you not
want in this tourney deviled what egg
went to the top
devil yeah but you're saying it like you
scramble you're telling me like you
thwarted me the reason i didn't want
deviled in is because i didn't think it
was a fair comparison because it's it
has other ingredients in it it's weird
you haven't said that a thousand times
why are you so happy then
is the reason i thought it would be in
and i didn't want it in the tournament
but you're telling me like you got me i
got you you didn't yes i did i thought
it would go far because it's not just
plain you're just mad that your
cadbury's not in it anymore
and that was the fake egg you picked
cadbury it was
i know you already explained it
you already explained it don't explain
it again yeah please we've all heard
enough
i don't even understand when i'm around
you i start you you make me feel like
i'm going crazy but i know for a fact
that i'm not
you're the crazy one i'll read the
comments let's read the comments i don't
need to read comments i know you don't
you shouldn't read them don't read them
for all that is holy stay away from the
comments joe
don't read them because people see what
i see i'm telling you that all right
here we go
pimp two minute clock
and this is it one minute this is it two
minute clock for the final battle ready
deviled eggs
they went to the top you have nothing to
say in the original devilx battle you
said jack [ __ ] i talked for four minutes
and he went deviled eggs i'm gonna tell
you and then what happened
as you say as you say that my egg needs
all these extra things right
i want to point out that your your lead
word one of the lead words you use for
scrambled was buttery
buttery you that is an added ingredient
there you go okay take out buttery so
now what do you have you have a
beautifully light fluffy scrambled egg
light and fluffy if
you add milk yeah if you do not add milk
you are not getting a fluffy egg okay
joe extra ingredient okay yeah but it's
no oh but it's my argument so what
you're saying doesn't mean well you're
getting
mustard bacon mayo chives nobody's
adding bacon and chives i don't know
where you're getting that from okay
you're writing what what are you adding
mustard mayo sprinkling paprika on top
i'm done i'm out the door so you're even
putting okay yeah you know what good
don't let it hit you on the way out go
go you you you have a deviled eggs in
the finale of a tournament you have said
nothing to defend them in the last hour
you just grind it
it's tangy it slides down i hate the
tanginess of a deviled egg it slides
down okay
it goes down easy it doesn't give me a
stomachache slides down doesn't give me
a
stomachache i scramble scrambled eggs
give me stomachaches
these are not greasy it is literally a
diarrhea guarantee oh stop it
scrambled eggs are so greasy you get a
stomach ache every time sliding down
deviled eggs in a hot outdoor barbecue
we've been on vacay together where i've
had to pass up on the community
breakfast in the house because i can't
eat scrambled eggs because they give me
such a bad stomach cake because why are
you eating greasy
deviled eggs are not greasy scrambled
eggs are not greasy they're cooked in
grease i don't cook my scrambled eggs
and grease you're cooking them in oil
how are you laminating your pan how are
you laminating your pan i'm not
you're out of your mouth maybe a little
butter maybe a little pam but butter
once again non-cooking non-stick cooking
spray like buttery eggs all right look
that's battling what's cooking this
scrambled eggs
takes the 20. let's see who takes twenty
it's time yeah you just all you wanna do
is you wanna look at statistics you
don't wanna stay right here where the
real battle is
here we are for your scrambled eggs are
greasy 4 200 votes 4 200 votes oh it's
only been up a minute
no but i'm saying that's good
here's where men are made
this is where you're going where you
going pimp
i can't wait till
[Laughter]
take your deviled eggs and shove them up
your hole
please
70 70.3 to be exact for scrambled if you
count at home 29.7 for the devil god
damn it
for the devil himself
the fact that you had the you had the
stones you had the eggs to think that
deviled egg was going to beat scrambled
scrambled is the premiere egg
preparation i took i rode my egg to the
top and i didn't know where we were
going to land i could have been against
cadbury in this final round i don't know
but i picked an egg i believe didn't i
still believe devil beat hard-boiled huh
devil beat hard-boiled and
scrambled beat it by that much yeah
it beat hard-boiled wait how did cadbury
get knocked out
cat what do you mean how did it scramble
scrambled knocked out cadbury no no it
didn't yeah it did
no oh yeah it did okay
all right just want you know scrambled
beats sunny side up cadbury and deviled
scrambled is the king big surprise
everybody sal picks the the public
favorite wow
you hated
[Music]
horses in this race this is what you
guys don't see off camera
you'll be like you're like sal what do
you want to battle you want to battle uh
you want to battle a hitler versus
seinfeld and i'll go
i gotta i love the battle babe they're
powerhouses i gotta pick seinfeld can
you take hitler that's that's sour at
every battle how untrue that is that's
everybody moments ago you wanted to do
oatmeal versus cold cereal and i told
you xiao i don't think you should do it
joe because cold cereal is
did the exact opposite of what you said
i would be doing this is myself
this is my sound pressure
babe powerhouse battle hang gliding
versus public shooter i'm gonna have to
take hang gliding
can you take public shooter
that's a really funny little joke that
you cobbled together but i swear to god
if it's based in here
[ __ ] the thing that i do the most
with you the most is because you go i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll tell you i'm like
joe do you want to do chicken noodle
soup you're like let's do chicken
noodles it's the opposite i got you
right piled up now i got you right now i
got an idea let's do chicken noodle soup
it's a pile of [ __ ] and i go joe i know
you don't like chicken noodle soup but
it's gonna beat a pile of [ __ ] you
shouldn't do that i don't care i'll take
it yeah you do it all the time you do it
all the time how dare you look at me
and not confess to them all you do is go
i don't care i'll take it anyway i i'm
always banging the drum that it's not
gonna be a good battle i don't want to
landslide battles guess what you just
wanted to put oatmeal against all cold
cereals guess what guess what
i lost i'm calm i ruined your win look
how angry you are right now out of here
you should
you should be more concerned about your
losses i tell you that much it's because
you haven't paid a consequence for
losing season one yeah this is a win
this is a win
that got you all worked up yeah but you
couldn't get the other you just lie
how about we do truth verse lies
you take lies and then tell me
let's end it yeah let's get it
i got new
[Laughter]
right now this weekend i'm gonna be in
san diego in l.a at the wilton on may
21st and 22nd and right now on sale
literally as of this past friday right
now on sale is las vegas phoenix boulder
colorado portland seattle and vancouver
they're on sale right now they just went
on sale two days ago this posted after
the 21st and 22nd
no this is coming out on the on
23rd oh [ __ ]
thank you la in san diego
i still love you babe
oh oh because i don't have any plugs
only the big guy is plucked i didn't
know you wanted to do plugs you just
said you don't want to do them i want to
do mine are you not supposed to we're
supposed to only do them at the top it's
supposed to all right i'm sorry talk to
hr all right all right well i'm gonna do
them now too come to joey roses you know
why you could you know why you fall
asleep when i was talking about tattoos
because you're you're in bed
you're laying down can i do my plugs you
don't have enough you don't even have
enough respect to sit up and do this can
we do my plug so i can wrap it up please
joey roses come on down open tuesday
through sunday people uh go to
joeyrosesnyc.com for details i will be
at the thank you austin i was just there
you were wonderful
i will be at the punchline in san
francisco in july
uh tickets i believe are available now
and i've got more dates posting for
august september october
and november uh and word on that is
coming very soon so we'll talk to you
later
still love you man love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds